[Music]
top story at five we're learning more
tonight about a health district
investigation revealing norovirus caused
a lot of people to get sick at a Valley
Elementary School thanks for joining us
at five I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian
Loft his parents telling us over a
hundred students were infected a teacher
in the school district telling us
another story Ryan Matthey joining us
live in studio though with the
comparison right yeah Denise Bryan this
was all first reported just a couple
weeks ago Friday January 27th more than
100 students reportedly vomiting at the
same time this is the letter Tanaka
Elementary says it sent to parents the
same day advising of an investigation
then just this week the health district
revealing norovirus could have caused it
but certain pieces to this puzzle remain
missing
aches in the stomach which were severe
Brianna Aguilar says her five-year-old
daughter brought something home she
shouldn't have it was in line it was
like my daughter my son me and then my
husband her entire family including
one-year-old Nye caught the virus
spreading through Wayne and Tanaka
Elementary School in Spring Valley that
an 8 news now Source said infected
roughly 130 students but there was
probably 10
to 12 chairs the most in the hallway but
this second grade teacher there says the
number infected was significantly lower
than what our sources call a throw-up
apocalypse it was definitely different
I've never been through that before but
those all those kids came back on Monday
I haven't had anybody abstinent but
they're not uncommon in school settings
but the questions remain what caused it
and how many infected the Southern
Nevada Health District reporting
preliminary findings on Tuesday
norovirus commonly spread from person to
person by consuming infected food or
touching something contaminated than
putting that in their mouth how they
test for it
stool samples communicable disease
supervisor Haley Blake says the health
district continues to investigate the
cause whether from infected cafeteria
food or something else one person may
have eaten the contaminated food and
then they became ill and then people may
have inadvertently been exposed to that
vomit and then 12 hours 12 hours 48
hours later then now they are sick it
was off the charts unusual I've never
seen that in my life was I worried no
now I also asked CCSD what they're doing
to prevent something like this from
happening again but instead of answering
that a representative told me Ace or the
school underwent a deep cleaning
following the mass vomiting episode
Brian Denise
Ryan thanks for the update but did the
district offer Ryan the following
information so CCSD revealing just 84
percent of students remained at school
the day of the mass illness that number
then dropped to 78 the following Monday
now keep in mind the average attendance
on any given day is 93 percent